hey guys welcome back and I hope you
enjoyed our last episode today we are
bringing you an absolutely Savage
money-making method the method involves
filling a sack with 10 cabbages it's
that simple no prerequisites are
required so anyone can do it as you can
see they sell for 1K each nearly
doubling the price of the supplies
required before we start I highly
recommend using a oneclick bank such as
Castle Wars Clan Wars dual Arena Etc
because this is a very click intensive
method now let's jump into it
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
after 1 hour of filling sacks with
cabbages subtracting the cost of the 49
GP cabbages and the 3 GP sacks I've
acquired
830k as I said earlier this method has
absolutely zero requirements therefore
it is one of the most profitable
low-level money-making methods in the
game I never had trouble selling or
buying the items but if you encounter a
problem leaving the purchase overnight
will work anyway I hope you guys are
enjoying the series remember to like
comment and subscribe if you want to see
more until next time